herzlich willkommen hier bei bild live
und wir statt mit einer breaking news es
gab schüsse während einer wahlkampfrede
auf den japanischen ex-premier shinzo
abe es besteht lebensgefahr
attentat auf shinzo abe der frühere
japanische regierungschef fällt gerade
eine wahlkampfrede in der alten
kaiserstadt nara als schüsse fallen
der 67 jährige wird getroffen und bricht
zusammen
sofort stürzen sich sicherheitsbeamte
auf den mutmaßlichen täter ein 41
jähriger mann wird noch am tatort
verhaftet neben ihm auf dem boden die
vermeintliche tatwaffe selbst gebaut aus
zwei rohren und sprengstoff shinzo abe
wird sofort in ein krankenhaus gebracht
es gibt befürchtungen dass er den
anschlag nicht überleben könnte laut dem
japanischen fernsehsender nhk dollar
beko laviert und einen herz lungen
stillstand erlitten haben shinzo abe
hatte japan von 2012 bis 2020 regiert
trat dann aus gesundheitlichen gründen
zurück er war der am längsten amtierende
premier des landes
bleiben wir natürlich dran halten sich
hier auf dem laufenden